et l'ancienne première ministre du
québec pauline marois est avec nous en
sommes à damas roi vincent van damme
galipeau alors rené lévesque en quoi
était il si différent des hommes d
autres hommes politiques parce qu'il a
tellement marqué les québécois c'était
un homme hors nature c'est une grandeur
par nature c'était un homme d'abord
d'une grande intégrité
une grande intégrité très respectueux de
son peuple il aimait passionnément le
québec et l'aimé passionnément les
citoyennes et citoyens du québec et il
se préoccupait du bien commun c'était sa
raison la raison de son engagement en
politique et en ce sens oui il était
différent des personnes politiques
souvent que l'on rencontre ou pas
fonctionnement c'est notre rêve un peu
plus pour elles mêmes que pour les
causes qu'elles ont endossé alors que
rené lévesque c'était très profond chez
lui que cet engagement c'est presque un
attachement et motifs des québécois avec
vie parce que les québécois santé qu'il
les aimait les québécois santé qu'il
travaillait pour pour les aider pour les
accompagner moi j'ai vécu plein
d'expérience avec lui où il nous
demandait d'être à l'écouté de nos
concitoyens pour que nos politiques
correspond et répond à leurs besoins et
ça chez et puis en plus évidemment c'est
un grand démocrate alors il ne voulait
pas qu'on bouscule les québécois ça
aussi c'était important quand on
arrivait avec des projets politiques
étaient assez audacieux et voulait y en
a mais beaucoup avaient beaucoup puis on
a eu beaucoup ce sont aux gouvernements
mais voulez qu'on aille à la rencontre
qu'on peut se consulter les entendre
mais aussi qu'on soit capable de prendre
des décisions et sa grande je dirais son
grand legs à cet égard c'est d'avoir
rendu les québécois fier fier et
confiant en eux-mêmes de d'aller au bout
d'être capable d'aller au bout de leurs
possibilités
nous sommes capables et à travers toutes
les grandes politiques qu'il a mis de
l'avant que ce soit la question la
langue la protection du territoire
l'assurance auto qui sont des pièces
maîtresses qui sont toujours d'actualité
qui ont toujours leur impact
essentiellement donc c'était de servir
les québécoises est qu il y avait cette
authenticité quand il disait quelque
chose comme un grand peuple
on sent que ce qu'il pensait et quand
ils arrivent au pouvoir il dit le soir
du 16 novembre mais ici on se tait pas
parfait peut-être qu'on va se tromper
peut-être qu'on va faire des erreurs
mais sachez que ce sera toujours de
bonne foi et parce qu'on aura voulu
faire au mieux prendre les meilleures
décisions
donc vous dites il laisse en héritage
cette intégrité 7 cet amour en fait un
des québécois mais il y a tellement de
grands projets de loi qui ont marqué le
québec on pense à la loi sur la
protection du territoire agricole le
financement les partis politiques la loi
101 voix saint cyr la langue est aussi
au début de son mandat il non seulement
il ya la loi sur le financement des
partis politiques mais va modifier
toutes les façons d'octroyer des
contrats il va donc introduire beaucoup
d'exigence au niveau de cet aspect est
important de la gestion de l'état de
telle sorte que il n'ya pas de toute
forme de patronage si on veut alors ça
ça l'avait beaucoup heurté quand il
était au parti libéral ou redonner les
contrats selon qui on connaît et ses
rangs alors ils avaient introduit des
lois des règlements pour que l'on soit
très juste équitable à cet égard alors
parmi tous ces grands projets de loi
s'ils en avaient un que vous deviez
choisir qu'est ce qui serait son suspect
- j'aime vraiment point de vue le plus
grand legs s'est de nouveau de nous
avoir redonné confiance en nous est de
nous avoir dit vous êtes capables on
n'est pas né pour un petit pain c'est
faux évidemment après sobre c'est la loi
101 c'est la langue qui a permis que
nous continuons de vivre en français
aujourd'hui ce qui était très périlleux
à l'époque où on est il est arrivé au
pouvoir
bêtement d'actualité ma mère est son
plus grand legs à mon point de vue c'est
celui-là c'est de nous avoir dit vous
êtes capable vous avez du talent et
retrouver la fierté de ce que nous
sommes oui vous avez été ministre
lançant dans le deuxième mandat du
cousin j'aime gouvernement lévesque et
vous étaient proches de lui de q2
comment vous vous souvenez de lui de la
ola là je me suis de lui comme un homme
droit un homme qui était à city milan
quand il se retrouvait avec quelques
personnes se loin il était plus que plus
capable c'est davantage capables de nous
transmettre un message quand on se
retrouver autour de la table des
consignes conseil des ministres que
lorsqu'on se retrouvait un petit groupe
séquence il y avait une certaine pudeur
finalement mais sinon il est est il
resté cet homme simple et il n'y avait
pas de double langage avec lui sans
aussi c'était rassurant quand il tenait
des propos il aurait pu les tenir
dehors comme à l'intérieur ils auraient
pu redire la même chose qui nous disait
devant une foule finalement parce que
encore une fois c'était son intégrité sa
sincérité et à cet égard c'est ce dont
je me souviens le plus de lui il n'était
pas parfait non mais les québécois ne
semble pas lui en avoir tenu rigueur
parce que bon on se souvient des images
à l'époque un objet et fumay il aimait
beaucoup les femmes disons le comme ça
vous fout et c'est vrai tu ressens mais
et parce que encore une fois il n'a
jamais trompé les québécois ils à
respecter la parole donnée et c'était
pas seulement un respect de surface où
c'était un respect profond parce que ils
avaient à coeur notre bien être
finalement et ça se sent il aimait les
gens et comme je dis souvent il avait le
coeur à la bonne place et ça ça ne
s'oublie jamais alors c'est dur de
passer à côté de cette campagne
électorale les s'amorce ghislain
bouchard évidemment eu ces propos qui
ont fait beaucoup réagir que le pq était
peut-être plus le bon véhicule pour la
souveraineté vous vous y croyez toujours
je vais voter pour le parti québécois
ce
qui est assez fascinant c'est que pour
un parti conduit un peu moribond c'est
vrai qu'il vit des difficultés on ne
peut pas le nier il a été capable de
réunir actuellement des dizaines de
candidates et de candidats qui sont des
jeunes candidats des jeunes candidats
quand un parti sur son déclin est ce que
la jeunesse ce rallye est ce que la
jeunesse a le goût de venir l'appuyer
moi je trouve que c'est de l'espoir que
de voir arriver ces personnes qui
s'engagent au niveau du parti québécois
alors ce parti qui a donné beaucoup au
québec nous en avons parlé avec rené
lévesque encore beaucoup à donner et
beaucoup à proposer et il porte un
projet qui est celui de la liberté d'un
peuple et celui de l'indépendance de la
souveraineté
à laquelle auxquelles je crois toujours
personnellement je ne reviendrai pas
quotidiennement dans la campagne mais il
y aura des moments où je serai invité à
prendre la parole et entre autres dans
des grands rassemblements ou jeu viendra
appuyer ma formation politique avec
beaucoup de conviction encore merci
beaucoup alain marois merci